previously on logos a 55 second
masterpiece of local action I used to
think this was the beginning of your
story
wait we get narration and foreshadowing
in the first line of the movie this must
be a prestige film
luckily for Louisa's grief wandering
there are no other staff or patients in
this hospital and the overhead lights
are permanently set to twilight there
are days that define your story beyond
your life like the day they arrived
Louise plays the pronoun game with her
newborn baby so that her baby will
instinctively hate the pronoun game
later in life sure these assholes could
be grouped around the TV to watch Maury
reveal who the father is but Louise
seriously doesn't give a cursory glance
at the screen to see what almost
everyone in the vicinity is gathering to
watch where is everyone the real
question is who are these Booker's who
weren't plugged in enough to have at
least some idea of what's going on these
are the few dedicated students that
showed up to class so you got to think
they're pretty engaged so why the fuck
do you keep your ringer on and answer
that fucking phone after class begins
and she's in the middle of the second
row any news you want to share your
pranks can you turn the TV to a news
channel huh you can't fool me this is
just a different wording for her you
better take a look at this cliche denis
villeneuve chooses to focus the camera
on Louise in her class as they watch the
stunning news about the alien arrival
which is probably a great artistic
choice and it keeps the alien ships a
mystery until the big reveal later but
what about my needs also is if to punish
her for interrupting class Louise steps
right in front of the student that asked
to watch the TV
[Music]
most modern buildings include visual
strobes in each room that go off with
the auditory alarm system so this school
is either an accidental violation of the
a da or is it dick to the
hearing-impaired or both also um either
these students are the calmest kids ever
in a disaster or else everyone's
incredibly high right now
this person is a dick - pulling out
which is probably why he has so many
child support payments okay we don't
know for sure at which university Louise
works but in Harvard so how can she
afford this sweet-ass modern lakefront
house on a professor's salary jeez
Louise
if your mom wants to watch some
cinemasins just let her have her fun
nope in fact Louise pretty much keeps up
this monotone vibe for the entire film
why this room sure does look neat and
tidy for a room where everybody left in
a hurry recently did the cleaning crews
still come in while the rest of the
world was caught up in an alien frenzy
Louise realizes if she hadn't brought
that burnt casserole to the last faculty
function someone might have called her
to let her know schools canceled GT
level when I pulled up to this empty
campus I thought no way she here today
thank God I completely ignored my gut
and my common sense and found you anyway
also no phone call on email
telex you all are the top everyone's
pretty close to translations and you
have another two years
yes SBI thanks for the expositional
resume girl so you still have top-secret
clearance he's robbing your office not a
Berkeley Weber just said Louise is at
the top of the list so isn't that why
he's here talking to her in fact because
he says this for basically no reason she
knows Weber's going to visit a brothel
translator and she's got just the plan
to make him look bad how many I'm
speaking to god damn they took out even
half the length of the pauses in
conversation in this movie denis
villeneuve could have trimmed 20 minutes
off this thing are you sure did they
have now how would you approach
translating this look I know Colonel
ghost dong here as a military dude
that's used to getting stuff done but
this line of questioning is total bull
does he really think Louise is gonna be
able to translate if she doesn't know
whether or not the aliens have mounds I
can tell you that it's impossible to
translate from an audio file I would
need to be there to interact with them
you didn't need that the foster
translation furthermore this guy
actually thinks an alien language can be
translated from a couple of noises on a
recording he mentioned Berkeley are you
going to ask Danvers next before you
commit to him ask him the Sanskrit word
for war and it's translation whoa does
she just have one of these trick
questions in her arsenal for every other
contemporary linguist competi
much dynasty he says if he's an argument
what do you savings a desire for cows
weep what how does this prove anything
also how does he know Louise had the
correct translation
did he google it and if so why didn't
the berkeley professor google it thank
you bags
god damn it does whipper seriously not
have a phone she could have been ready
before he got here and Hawkeye and Lois
Lane in the same movie that beats my DC
Marvel crossover fanfiction language is
the foundation of civilization is the
first weapon drawn in a conflict only
characters in this movie just spout off
random diatribe instead of just first
introducing themselves you know what
this movie is an amazing feat doesn't
get distracted by bullshit it's a
throwback to another era where it takes
time to build a story it says I've got
your sins right here cinema sin and you
can go fuck yourselves I've got to admit
that's rude but it's worth three sins
off don't look at the giant alien egg
don't look at the giant alien egg don't
look at the dammit
you won't be needing your cellphone's
here because we communicate by showing
up at your door unexpectedly just
getting started
good morning I guess Forest Whitaker's
accent could be described as
occasionally new y'all Stan I'm waiting
to tell you this detail until we're
literally standing underneath it this
moment behold the power of show don't
tell kids so good I mean look this is
totally good enough for a roll credits
in who ever could have said anything
like they'll be here shortly
go up and talk to them but this they
arrived response contains about the
least amount of information you could
give
man these have to pond sure do know how
to make an entrance huh it's not like
they couldn't already be there waiting
for the humans considering they know
exactly what time will show up dr. max
[Music]
start from what I realize we're gonna
get a lot of scenes in this corridor but
this is a jarring ass cut when we could
actually get to see what Lois first move
was wait Webber specifically mentioned
that Louise was at the top of the list
for translating the aliens so who was
the last guy violence continues to
spread across the u.s. today in the wake
of the 12 landings man this movie's
never seen an expositional TV monitor
that it doesn't want to shove down our
throats trying written language with
this board seems like a great idea until
someone needs to know which of the six
oxygen tanks are full sorry guys
needed to get an ink pen that's why I
left yeah I know it looks like I'm
writing this using my creepy alien claw
but I assure you there's a pin there
trying to speak and read that's got to
take longer well since he put it like
that I guess it shuts Webber's argument
totally down with no supporting evidence
I mean she's obviously right but it's
much more within Louise's character to
explain what she actually means so
you're gonna have to give me one net
kangaroo Titmouse
i love playing this game and he asked
what they were and the aborigine said
kangaroo a new point is what's this
whole conversation written with the idea
that they needed to give Forest Whitaker
more lines because Louise always make
sure she confuses the shit out of Webber
before getting to the point it's a good
story it's not true it proves my point
if this approach works than the entire
success of this peaceful alien encounter
rests on a statement that no one
fact-checked if one person on Webber's
committee says wait that sounds like
bullshit then this whole thing spirals
out of control don't you see they can't
seem to follow our algebra the aliens
are the equivalent of most us high
school sophomores yes so that we can
learn their names if they have names and
then introduce pronouns later we know
why you want to introduce the pronouns
dr. banks you're trying to get an
intergalactic pronoun game started
aren't you it's all great school words
eat mock help me understand
seriously as Weber this fucking dense
does he want to start the conversation
with the alien race with words like
lugubrious or surreptitious or something
first we need to make sure that they
understand what a question is if she had
this explanation in her back pocket then
why did she ever go with the kangaroo
story I'm wondering when this alien race
rights books
do they have to stop writing when they
run out of ink and wait until their
bodies build up more
how many antelopes time for this alien
cultures driving book scene so what are
we gonna call I was thinking Abbott and
Costello isn't the whole point of this
to learn what the aliens language means
so now Louise and Ian are just gonna
make up names for them instead of trying
to figure out what their actual names
are here are some of the many things we
don't know about hip de pods mid movie
completely out of nowhere narration this
narration appears to break the fourth
wall it is so jarring it's like we are
dropped into Planet over three not
planet Earth with no warning are these
scientists we're tourists if they're
scientists they don't seem to ask a lot
of questions
how would Ian know if they did Louise is
still trying to figure out the language
Ruby spends almost an hour with human
and Louise and Ian and then just throws
out all the words they've learned since
without actually showing us any of that
progress next expanding vocabulary
Louise thinks it could easily take
another month to be ready for that three
full minutes later and we are finally
finishing up the hard core narration
exposition seriously I haven't been mid
movie exposition this hard since the Big
Short I guess I swear I'm single trust
me you can understand communication and
still end up single nerd flirting
flirting was your last checkup we
thought together is it just me or is
Forrest just a glorified babysitter for
these two he's basically everyone's nose
he grandma Mabel at this point
explain this to me again would you did
you see the doctor if he asks about the
consistency of their bowel movements I'm
shifting my sergeant grannie theory from
plausible to confirm no mandarin wait a
second you're telling me that you don't
have an on site dedicated mandarin
expert later we see what looks like
translators for all the other languages
and locations so why do you need Banksy
here for the Mandarin was there
something more important going on where
all the Mandarin speakers had to be an
orange festival a lame Iron Man sequel
seeds on ur flowers colonel those are
all tile sets in mahjong Jesus Christ I
know Louise is a all-knowing linguist in
all but she's also a vintage game expert
God are they are they using a game to
converse with their Hebda pots and if
they're playing mahjong they're also
teaching the hepta pawns to become
stereotypical retirees why is anyone
still wearing these suits if Ian and
Louise have been running around in their
under clothes for at least a month now
with no ill effects wouldn't you think
for mobility and accuracy sake you'd go
ahead and let the other strip down too
it's quite possible that they're asking
us off for them something not the other
way around the first part of trade so
how do we clarify their intentions
beyond those two words I mean did she
not ask any follow-ups while she was
there they say offer weapon and she
immediately says okay take it easy the
hell's Denmark doing here the only site
with a shell landing that's not
represented here is Greenland so movies
saying Denmark is calling the shots for
them it's over 1,800 miles away we need
to be talking to each other I want to
talk to them find out what this means
but he just said it's more complicated
when Louise asked to go back into the
hepta pod chamber to figure this about
Jesus template asshole CIA plot mover
can't even asshole consistently so there
are at least four of these morons in on
the plan and not one of them stop to
think about how stupid this idea was
seriously what's the best-case scenario
here that's somehow our poultry human
explosive will detonate the entire ship
and then Independence Day style take out
the other 11 as well
Oh beer is movie also Louise can't take
a sheet of vocabulary words with her on
the ship without ever looking them over
but somehow these Yahoo's get a bomb
through security and onto the ship also
also doesn't everyone go back to camp
together so how did no one notice these
assholes stamp on these mothers are
moving rather casually considering they
just set a big bomb to go off in ten
minutes right above where they are
currently standing Mars but why I
understand these military dicks want to
blow up the ship they seriously don't
mind killing two civilians that are
still incredibly useful to this
operation
this look is called that jeremy renner
however wants me to write on the barrier
can you even do that I don't know how
does she know abot once her to write on
the barrier he'd stuck his suction cup
thing up on there but he could just want
her to give him a high-five wait how did
they see the blast itself the hepta pons
blue Louise and Ian out of there with
their equipment so there shouldn't be an
inside view day 27 but didn't he say
earlier in his info dump it's taken us a
month to make the simplest for plotting
and Louise thinks it could easily take
another month to be ready for that
I mean maybe he didn't quite get to
another full month but still it was at
least three or four days before they
even got there and it's been at least
another week or two since that narration
if they took a month to even reply we
should be at least today 41 or so in a
televised statement general Shang
chairman of the People's Liberation Army
said the aliens have 24 hours to leave
Chinese territory or face destruction
and Shang knows the aliens understand
this ultimatum how I guess the people
watching the monitors got bored with
looking at these disconnected
notifications and rearranged them into
two rows considering this was the
previous arrangement even one of the
most intelligent sci-fi films ever made
can't resist a little zoom and enhance
slap and tickle it's going to take us
years or they could just do another one
of those sped up montage thingies and
have this figured out in less than 10
minutes is that all of the pieces I'm
telling you that no one else cares holy
SH the CIA guy is such an unrelenting
dickhead he may as well have been played
by James Woods nonzero-sum game that's
it actually Anna wanted to know what you
called a competition where both sides
ended up happier win in a nonzero-sum
game it's not required for both sides to
win because it would include negative
some games the correct answer would have
been a positive sum game look they're
not our enemy they've made no active
aggression towards us that's a good
point
they've been there for what months and
nothing has happened that would make
anyone think the aliens are evil with
the exception of some things they've
communicated that could be and have
easily been explained away good to know
that even though this was a
time-sensitive mission Ian and Louise
took the time to teach the aliens the
names they gave them also do they
understand English now is she speaking
telepathically or were they pretending
not to understand the whole time so that
we could learn by teaching them seems
like whatever the case if they're beings
who exist at once throughout all time
and no English there might have been a
better way to teach this what is your
purpose here
now they tell them that would have been
helpful the first time they were asked
the question who is this child show is
called mommy and daddy talked to animals
cop damn this reveal just melted my
brain and I'm temporarily unable to use
lowercase text once it off while I cool
down you know what guys
subway is really going too far with our
ads these days advanced alien race is
not bound by time or space and it can't
clear a few electricity poles more like
hepta clods look I understand that this
movie is operating on some sort of
self-consistency principle and that time
is not linear all things that have
happened and will happen or essentially
set in stone but is this movie really
saying that because she saw the future
book that's how she solved the language
and then she wrote a book based on
seeing the book she would one day right
Weber suddenly turns into a disbelieving
dick to deliver this line even after
witnessing Louise's solo trip inside the
ship
I guess the CIA asshole is busy packing
or something no you know do not claim to
know how your mind works yet I just did
something incredibly intuitive that
becomes the movies most convenient plot
point I caught you tonight yes you did
why is Louise surprised by this if this
is the actual future she's living in she
would know this is coming we understand
that our present Louise is just
experiencing this but she should be
experiencing it as a future participant
in the same way that she has lived the
other future moments the movie does a
good job of staying to a lock timeline
theory of time dispersion but slips up
in this one moment of future ignorance
TLDR wibbly-wobbly timey-wimey random
satphone is random and convenient and
without a secure entry system
I would never I can't point your sand I
get that this is nonlinear thinking as
opposed to actual time travel but still
the scene was very convenient that she
realized all of us now as opposed to
when they were say already on the
helicopter headed out of here if he
could see her whole life from start to
finish would you change things Pam the
Wiis is really setting up Ian here this
is like a long con version of the blame
game you know I've had in my head tilted
up to the stars for as long as I can
remember
no it surprised me the most it wasn't
meeting them is meeting you even after
hearing this cheesy line but we still
eventually wants to pee you like it hot
don't you guys ahead look the city is
flying we're fighting an army of robots
and have a bow and arrow none of this
makes sense
[Music]
is there air Oh Billy